so what I'm going to do here is start
our discussion on DC's darkside war and
the cool thing here is that Geoff Johns
wraps everything we need to know
regarding the new gods and darkside into
a small package within this comic now
something I want to go over here first
is a man named Metron with the events
that we'll see are told from his
perspective and truth Metron is largely
ambiguous at best when Jack Kirby had
left Marvel in DC in 1971 he launched
something called the 4th world which saw
the introduction of Darkseid and the new
gods but also created Metron the issue
here is that when Kirby left DC and went
back to Marvel in 1976 much of the
fourth world was left unfinished and as
a result there was no true origin
provided for Metron except to say that
he's vastly powerful and travels the
multiverse recording everything from his
mysterious Mobius chair which allows him
to move through time and space
instantaneously and so what we're going
to find in this comic is that geoff
johns is going to set the stage for
Darkseid war by consolidating all
available information on Metron and
presenting it accordingly so as the
story opens up what geoff johns does
here is really intriguing the narrative
of Metron tells us that since the DC
universe came into existence worlds
realities and even multiverses as a
whole have been created and destroyed
over and over again where the death and
rebirth of all things largely go
unnoticed by its occupants and that
their lives start fresh with no
recollection of the previous events
because Metron exists outside of space
and time he's basically witnessed the
destruction of all things and the
rebirth using the example of a man named
Wilson Morgan the purpose of his place
in this story is to simply provide us
with an alternate reality where Wilson
was a survivor of the Amazo virus to
sidetrack for a second the Amazo virus
was a concept that appeared in new 52
Justice League with issues 35 to 39
engineered by Lex Luthor for the purpose
of suppressing the abilities of
super-powered people the Amazo virus was
accidentally unleashed on the world
whenever it affects normal people those
individuals to come in three stages and
stage one the experience flu-like
symptoms including muscle aches
headaches dry cough and a sore throat
and stage two they begin to develop
superhuman abilities based on the sub
consciousness of the victim and that
those who are obsessed with fire will
develop fire related abilities and so
after 24 hours into stage 2 the victim
will move into stage 3 whether blood
becomes black the hearts burst and their
brain melts resulting in their death in
the reality that wilson morgan hails
from after the Amazo virus had spread he
along with a handful of others survived
and kept their superhuman abilities now
again this portion of the story isn't
really significant to the events that
will unfold
instead it's simply designed to provide
us with an example of the life that
Metron leads as he explains because
Wilson developed powers but had no real
training on how to use them he found
himself acting as an unpolished hero and
was ultimately killed while trying to
solve a kidnapping and during the final
moments of his life he was able to see
Metron now this is particularly
interesting and that what Jeff Jones is
doing here is making the case that if
Metron has been observing every major
event that has ever transpired in the
history of DC Comics that he can only be
viewed under two circumstances the first
is that he allows someone to see him and
the second is that a person is on the
verge of death while Jeff Jones doesn't
really provide a reason here with Metron
simply stating that this is a mystery to
him the narrative of Metron tells us
that as a silent observer with the lives
of everyone a virtually meaningless to
him the existence of the multiverse is
of the utmost importance and that if it
were to end while he would live on his
purpose as an observer and chronicler
would cease to be now where Jones is
being very cloak-and-dagger here
regarding what he means what we'll find
throughout this comic is that all of
this would be cleared up but again much
like The Watcher from Marvel Comics
Metron has only intervened a few times
in the history of his existence and the
first time that this happened was during
an impending war between Darkseid of
apocalypse and highfather of New Genesis
as the oldest being in the universe
aside from Metron himself the conflict
between Darkseid and highfather is as
old as time what we're told here is that
every ten years the two planets of
Darkseid and highfather would move
closer to one another and that at some
point Darkseid and highfather
made battle plans for war against one
another however because their conflict
would likely lead to the end of the
multiverse due to the incredible power
that they possess Metron intervened by
having the two swaps sons now this is
particularly important and the reason
why is because prior to this and the
original fourth world story Kirby had
written the idea that Darkseid and
highfather swap suns of their own
in order to keep their own worlds from
being destroyed again while this isn't
of the utmost importance at the moment
it points us in the direction of Geoff
Johns retconning some of DC's history
and reconciling various themes now from
here we jump to Metron discussing the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths
and at this point we joined geoff johns
on his explanation of the flaw in the DC
Universe where Metron talks about how
the crisis on Infinite Earths and
subsequent events like zero our crisis
in time Infinite Crisis and final crisis
as well as flashpoint all saw the in
continuity destruction of the multiverse
and its rebirth in truth Geoff Johns is
using this as a metaphor for his
perception of DC as a company while this
is largely hearsay and that I can't
speak for John's directly I would argue
that from his eyes the reboots of DC's
continuity have been a major source of
contention from fans and that they
became attached to an aspect of a
character that the continuity is
rebooted and that all the connection is
lost as a result within the context of
the story the concert rebooting of the
multiverse has left all reality in a
fragile state and that it can all come
to an end again serving as a metaphor to
the idea that reception of the new 52
was not well received any future reboots
of DC's continuity could very well
destroy fans trust in the company now at
this point the journey transitions to
Metron on earth as he tracks down
anti-monitor however in this story we're
going to be delving into uncharted
waters with virtually all new
information coming out about his
character what I mean here is that
historically anti monitors name had
never been revealed and he was simply
used as a plot device for crisis on
Infinite Earths to allow CEC to reboot
his continuity while he had subsequent
appearances and stories like Green
Lantern blackest night and brightest day
none of these appearances featured
anti-monitor as a multiverse ending
entity in this story Geoff Johns is
quite literally creating new information
in this story as he says the
anti-monitor is actually a being named
mobius now the indication here is that
there is some back story between Metron
& anti-monitor but Geoff Johns doesn't
delve into this during this part of the
story instead he establishes a couple of
important elements between the two the
first is that while Metatron sits on the
Mobius chair he's immune to the powers
of anti-monitor
now where John's does not provide a
reason for this this is actually
established information and that the
Mobius chair has
force field that were Texas user from
all forms of energy attacks furthermore
the Mobius chair belonged to
anti-monitor at some point in the past
and for reasons unknown it was vacated
and presumably handed over to Metron in
addition to this Metron states that
because the multiverse has been
destroyed and recreated multiple times
it exists in an extremely fragile state
and is on the verge of complete and
total collapse and so what geoff johns
also does here is a swage fan belief
that the anti monitors appearance means
that DC is planning another reboot by
having the anti-monitor state but he has
no intention of destroying all of
reality and so offering a packed
Metron state set of anti-monitor is
willing to put aside his actions Metron
will focus his efforts on restoring
anti-monitor
to the way that he used to be prior to
his evolution into his current form now
again Geoff Johns does not provide any
clarification here and for myself I
don't really know what he's referencing
here and this indicates that John's
intends to create a backstory to the
character of anti-monitor
and the idea that he was likely a normal
being and was somehow cursed a damnation
as a consumer of realities to keep
himself alive and so as this pre lude
comes to a close the basis behind the
story comes into fruition when we
learned that anti-monitor is in pursuit
of this very goal and while Metron does
not possess the power to change it back
to the way he used to be darkside does
as a result anti-monitor intends to
launch a war against Darkseid in an
effort to be restored to his former self
however before any action can be taken
by either Metron or anti-monitor Metron
is attacked from behind by Grail the
daughter of Darkseid with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and if any of this was confusing
to you leave a comment below and I'll do
my best to clear it up but that being
said I will catch you guys on peace